هنا بدات القصه موقع ديسكورد
لقاء افتراضي لحوالي 30 فردا دردشه
اعتياديه لا غير شباب ومراهقين دقائق حتى
تحول الحديث دون قصد لتبادل الاهتمامات في
مناقشه الحرب في اوكرانيا وهنا وقع
المحظور
شاب عشرني يدير مجموعه دردشه يعمل منذ عام
في الحرس الوطني الجوي الامريكي نشرت
تلقائيا عشرات الوثائق العسكريه
جاك تكسيرا احرج امريكا واربك العالم بلا
قسط
الشرطه الامريكيه لم يغمض لها جفن
[موسيقى]
قبضت على تكسيرا للتحقيق في تسريبات وصل
صداها العالم غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات